ghost is probably one of my favorite
movies of all time these are the most
romantic big movie you know Whoopi
Goldberg Patrick Swayze you go and cut
your hair you decide I'm gonna get a
short haircut right before the filming
of ghost you don't talk to the director
who is director on that um Jerry Zucker
okay this guy hires you he sees you with
this little pixie haircut which was so
[__] adorable in the movie but he
envisioned a girl with long dark hair
being in ghosts I didn't even think
about it being a conflict until I saw
his face and I showed up and he was like
where's the hair yeah I hired to me more
who is this oh my God but did they
didn't work it [__] worked it was
fantastic because when you guys are
doing the pottery and you're just with
that little short haircut Makes You
Believe in Romance reading it on paper
yeah how was it when you read it
components like I I thought this is
either gonna be
amazing or an absolute disaster it's a
comedy a thriller and a romance
like how are they going to pull that off
Hard movie to pull off right
and it did like everything about it like
worked and dealing with the subject of
you know of afterlife and things that
people were not certainly as open to as
we are now and why I love reading your
book is you remind me that people were
not kind to that movie and I just
thought in my memory that the ghost was
like the movie you know it was just
insanely I I mean I saw the reviews and
I was so excited because I really felt
like what's the first review you read is
it like the New York Times I don't even
know remember what it was but I was so
shocked because I had watched it I was
with other people we all had the same
feeling and I thought what did what are
they seeing that I'm not and then I
decided I don't when you saw it when you
saw it did you say hey I've got a really
good movie here this is going to change
this is a game changer I thought it was
really great and then you read the
reviews and you're like oh [__] like I
must really be missing something I know
they see I'm centered it's like what are
they seeing that I'm not and there were
too many people really smart people that
felt the same way I did so think about
that role the way you were crying I mean
first of all most actresses can't cry on
command I I and by I don't feel like I
can but it happens you mean because you
were so involved in the scene you were
so focused on that scene that that
somehow in the scene you were able to
cry or did the director say to you
listen to me I need you to cry in this I
mean it was not written that I had to
but I felt like that was it's pivotal
when Whoopi pushes the penny under the
door and then Patrick starts to raise
the penny and he's bringing it toward
your face you begin to cry you realize
you're that This Woman's for real she's
not a charlatan and you're contacting
your dead husband and The Tear starts to
come down
I know it was the one eye thing one eye
that's a [__] moment
foreign